we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is once
again a caller absolutely destroying me
on something that i actually never said
and does not even align with my
political ideology what am i talking
about I'm talking about socialism and
Venezuela take a listen to this hey
David Pakman won't you just move on over
to Venezuela and quit it quit preaching
yet socialist [ __ ]
because that's what you are a socialist
and socialism is a a coconut butter damn
damn communist [ __ ] and on top of
all that they killed over a hundred
million people but I don't yes you know
that because you're a socialist and Yuri
yeah got cut off there listen I don't
I've made it abundantly clear that I'm
not a socialist and I've been
extraordinarily critical of the
Venezuela regime regime under Hugo
Chavez and now Nicolas Maduro
so criticize me for stuff I've said and
interestingly even after the Joe Rogan
appearance last week on which I said my
perspective here is not a socialist
perspective I'm a Social Democrat which
is a mixed economy it's a type of well
regulated capitalism
I still got a ton of emails and tweets
and if you look at the comments on the
Joe Rogan interview people saying why
did Joe Rogan have this socialist on to
socialism I'm not a socialist okay if
you disagree with me on the policies I'm
advocating tell me why the policies are
wrong but to call them socialist and say
that on that basis they are wrong or bad
I'm simply not a socialist and if I were
a socialist I would be telling you if
there is any there are many real serious
critiques that can be made of this
program one that cannot be made is that
I have been anything but completely open
and genuine with the audience about what
my views are I'm a Social Democrat not a
socialist if I were a socialist I would
tell you if I were a free-market
capitalist I would tell you period we've
got a great bonus show planned for you
today we have some new things going on
behind the scenes at the show which I
will tell you about former Red Sox
player David Ortiz has been shot and
hospitalized in the Dominican Republic
a very strange story
and very sad and the Boston mayor is
saying that the city cannot stop the
straight Pride Parade over the values
that it espouses we will talk about all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get instant access takes
under a minute to get instant access to
the bonus show as a member at david
pakman.com slash membership or as a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show